patience underoos hey everyone
hey youtubers is Charlie so since
comic-con has ended more awesome news
has been pouring out about spider-man
homecoming the director even teased some
iron spider stuff so this is gonna be a
breakdown of that one of the really
interesting things that the director of
the movie talked about after he showed
off the footage like after he went and
started talking to reporters was about
the suit itself now obviously it's the
same suit from Civil War the fun thing
that he teased is is that we might see
more suit related twists so people are
just thinking hey maybe he's talking
about iron spider are we finally going
to see the iron spider in the real twist
is is that Peter Parker is actually
already wearing the iron spider suit so
like what is the iron spider suit like
not literally wearing the iron spider
suit like the more burnt red with the
gold symbol like I'm not talking about
that when you think about it the iron
spider suit is a Tony Stark design stark
tech suit that's made to look like
Spider Man suit in the comics Tony
invented is this big upright like I've
been working on something for you kid
they did it on the spider-man cartoon
that's on Disney XD like they did the
spider verse so like they go to an
alternate universe where there is an
iron spider and it really is like an
Iron Man suit like he has repulsors he
can do pretty much anything that Iron
Man's suit does he has the same heads-up
display the Iron Man has inside his mask
so when the director of spider-man
homecoming says well it's a Stark built
suit we wonder what else can it do that
means that Peter Parker
Tom Hollands Peter Parker is already
wearing the iron spider suit is just
that in the MCU it's made to look like
the classic spider-man suit so we've
already seen the new mechanical
web-shooters we've seen that they have
like a special spider light there's
probably going to be a couple extra toys
that he finds out about early in the
movie like the spider trackers that's
one of the safer bets
I think like the extra stark tech that
he's going to discover as he starts
playing with his new car like imagine
Papa Tony buying him a new car for his
16th birthday so part of the fun of
driving a new car is learning all the
special things that it can do like you
start reading through the manual you're
like oh my god it can do all this
awesome stuff so I'm expecting part of
the fun of spider-man Home Coming which
is supposed to be a high school movie
through and through is going to be
watching Peter Parker learn all about
his new car and because it's Tony Stark
there are probably a couple
you'd a couple big surprises that will
see late in the movie like a third act
surprise during a big villain fight so
when we're talking iron spider tech I
think the things that we'll see in
spider-man homecoming will be relatively
practical like spider trackers pretty
safe bet the spider light we've already
seen I'm not expecting a whole bunch of
different kinds of web fluid I think
it'll just be one kinds of web fluid so
most of the stuff that you've already
seen from other spider-man movies not
too many surprises spider trackers I
think will be the fun surprise then late
in the movie I think we'll see like a
really big surprise like if you've never
seen this movie called The Last
Starfighter it's this really classic 80s
film it's you know very videogame heavy
it's kind of a ripoff on Star Wars but
in it this teenager who's like really
amazing at video games gets to fly this
Starfighter in this big Galactic war in
the ship has all these awesome weapons
all these awesome toys but his copilot
who's teaching him how to fly it tells
him not to press like this one button
he's like doh whatever you do do not
press that button so at the end of the
film when it looks like they're getting
ready to die this enemy fleet is all
around them they're surrounded by ships
his copilot is like okay now it's time
you can press that button like the
button that he was never supposed to
press so he presses it and it does this
giant super area of effect attack that
destroys all these ships around him so
they kind of did the same thing during
iron man to iron man to is a really good
example during that last boss fight when
they're surrounded by all those Hammer
drones iron man's like I got a surprise
up my sleeve and he has like the super
hardcore red laser that's like way more
powerful and he takes down all the
drones with a single attack I think
there'll be a moment like that in
spider-man homecoming relative to extra
stark tech on the suit so that will
probably be something closer to comic
book iron spider like something really
visually stunning that's also kind of
funny in like a big twist like something
you didn't expect so like a really good
example like the suit itself just looks
like the classic spider-man suit it
doesn't look that special but remember
during Civil War when the Winter Soldier
almost shoots Tony in the face but
Tony's stark tech watch turns into an
Iron Man hand piece and uses it to block
the bullet like his watch turns into a
small piece of an Iron Man suit
I think the Spider Man suit has some
stuff built into it like that like it
has some special stark tech that will
Manifest it helping with this badass
takedown of the big villain so let me
know in the comments what do you guys
think about the stark tech suit that
he's wearing right now
having some hidden surprises that will
see late in the film and like what do
you think we'll see from it early in the
film do you think we'll see spider
trackers and if there is a really
special iron spider surprise late in the
film like what do you think that's going
to look like do you think the spider
legs are going to pop out of his back do
you think the suit is going to manifest
a more metallic looking armor do you
think it's going to have some special
camo that would be another thing that's
actually a twist that's going on with
the Iron Man suit in the comics right
now so like in the comics you know he
has all the different versions of the
armor that do different things like he
has stealth armor he has armor that's
extra strong like the Hulkbuster the
armor that he's wearing right now during
civil war can just reconfigure to be any
of those armors that he needs so it'd be
really cool if the Spider Man homecoming
stark tech suit also was a little bit
like that like I'm not expecting the
twist to be super outlandish I think
it'll still be relatively practical but
everybody wants to see an iron spider
suit eventually and I love the idea that
he's already wearing it he just hasn't
figured it all out yet like he hasn't
completely read through the manual yet
like a typical high school student he I
mean he's a really brilliant person he
becomes a scientist eventually but like
all teenagers he's going to be a little
forgetful that'll cause some problems
during the movie so I'm just expecting
the movie to have some fun with like the
montage of him just like learning about
all the cool that his suit can do
so in related news the Marvel giveaway
is still going on all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on this video I'll be doing a
couple more Marvel videos as the week
gets on my next video will be an arrow
season 5 trailer video they're going
like hardcore Punisher this scene but
for those of you asking about spider-man
footage they're still in the middle of
principal photography I'm not expecting
them to release more spider-man footage
til the end of the year when they
release Doctor Strange I think they'll
attach like the first big big trailer to
that maybe to Star Wars rogue one at the
end of the year in December there's just
like two big Disney films coming out of
November it's Doctor Strange and then
Star Wars rogue one in December so just
expect a whole bunch of Marvel footage
for like guardians of the galaxy
spider-man homecoming to drop when those
movies premiere so while you guys wait
for that next video to post you can
click here for my breakdown of the
spider-man homecoming footage from Comic
Con you can click here for my breakdown
the full RAGBRAI footage thank you so
much for watching everybody let's high
five I'll see you guys tonight